well joining us now in the studio is
Adel Abdul kafer you're a fellow and
director of the foreign policy and
security program at the Middle East
Council on global Affairs thank you very
much for being with us um what do you
make of these attempts to to shift the
language to try to to budge the US away
from what has been at least in the
United Nations very very staunch support
of Israel well basically I think the US
is trying to change the language from
cessation to uh to suspension basically
what this indicates that the US
continues to provide political cover for
Israel at the UN despite of this ongoing
genocide in in Raza but also we also
have to look at the the secretary uh the
UN General Assembly as well where the
vote is non-binding but there's huge
support for cessation of of hostilities
yeah I mean the the language that was
already Rewritten for what was supposed
to be a vote on Tuesday talked about a
suspension of hostilities and Urgent
step towards a cessation sort of a more
permanent state of of ending uh the the
fighting um if that is not enough for
the US um what does that suggest I mean
is is this is there emergent division
within the United States Administration
itself or at least differences of
opinion that are that are making it more
difficult for the UN to the US rather to
sign up to anything yeah there could be
potential differences between the UN
team and for example the White House and
also if you look at the Secretary of
defense's visit as well uh to Israel
also from a from his perspective that
Israel should really ratchet down this
war because the cost is increasing ing
us is deployed and overstretched across
the region and now we see these
hostilities with the hthi attacking
Maritime shipping as well so there's
differences definitely within the US
Administration on how much time to give
to Israel to end uh uh this war you're
talking there about the situation in the
Red Sea with these Hy attacks and this
attempt um us-led attempt to try to uh
to interdict or or or try to to deter
the the huies from carrying on doesn't
seem to be much indication of success so
far although obviously very early days
is it a winnable situation for the
International Community for to try to
sort of defend global trade and its
ability to pass through this this
straight well this risks the further
expansion of of this conflict across the
region from a Hui perspective first of
all they want to support Palestine and
stop Israel's enablers and indicate that
they can have an impact on global
economy but also secondary objectiv is
also uh part of the negotiation with
Saudi Arabia uh and the truth in Yemen
so they also have an eye on that and
potentially this Mission will go ahead
and it's going ahead but you can
actually see that why Saudi Arabia and
Egypt and other Arab countries not want
to be part of any Coalition that is
perceived to protect Israeli shipping uh
for example so I think this Mission will
go go ahead but a lot of people have
doubts about the potential durability
and success in the long term I mean more
broadly um we have this attempt to to
sort of shift Israel's main Defender at
the UN we have the expanding situation
in the Red Sea all of it is an attempt
to pressure Israel to to stop the the
bombing campaign on Gaza um to what
extent can any of this do you think be
successful given Israel has stated its
War aims and for its own constituency
the Israeli government's own
constituency the Israeli people um sort
of stopping short of that is going to be
very difficult for them yeah I think
really we've had Global public opinion
really shift we've had the European
position shift the UK's position and
various other countries but basically
it's the US now that is enabling
Israel's genocide
in Gaza but I think from us perspective
uh as we enter the new year and we have
the US election I think there's also
political considerations electoral
considerations Biden's numbers are
really affected uh so basically I think
the the position is is to ratchet down
tensions and potentially end this war
before we get into the US election cycle
which should have an impact on Biden's
electability and we were also talking
with our correspondent Sara a bit
earlier about the attempts to get more
captives back on the from the Israeli
perspective um which would mean another
at least temporary cessation to what's
what's going on is there any Prospect do
you think of that I mean how how howas
going to react to those efforts do you
think any Seas fire is good because it
allows for the return of hostages and
prisoners to their families it allows
for the flow of of aid but the last
ceasefire basically established some of
this but did not provide a long-term
durable solution so if we stop the
conflict for one more week and then go
back to the indiscriminate bomb bombing
of Gaza what has this really achieved
right now what is needed is more durable
and long-term solution to end the whole
conflict inaz all right ad GAF thank you
very much for joining us on aler thank
you